it's really about getting out in the
mountains you'll never know until you go
out there you'll never know until you're
alone in the middle of the mountains and
you can't hear anything it's really a
different experience entirely than being
at this deal
core group of snowboarding's best riders
are leaving ski resorts manicured
terrain parks and Avalanche controlled
slopes to take their craft to the
wildest mountains they forgot the
standard practice taking a helicopter to
the summit and instead approach by foot
their tool of choice a splitboard
whoever came out with the split board it
was so awesome because basically you
just turn your snowboard into skis it
splits in half and you can use your
regular bindings they just clip on in a
different manner and then you can
essentially ski up and then put it back
together and snowboard down
the poor man helicopter even though
professional riders like Jonathan have
access to helicopters some of chosen
instead a more adventurous approach
climbing the lines they ride british
columbia in Alaska offer big mountains
and plenty of fresh snow
any adventure comes with hazards a split
boarding is no different vasas
Bergstrom's hanging glaciers Icefall
avalanche danger slough there's a ton of
potential in me hazards out in the
backcountry
safely negotiate the dangers split
borders must think collect mountain
climbers carefully assessing avalanche
danger and glaciated terrain because
every foot validation is earned with
sweat Fitness is paramount success so
yeah pretty much exactly where I want to
be so you want to ski down and get on
this side or shut down I call it steel
armor 23 hours you can get the best run
to your life you'll climb 2,000 feet and
all of a sudden get it come down this
amazing run
clothing about split boarding in just
the backcountry is you can make it
whatever you want it to be you could
make it as early as possible or you can
usually do it pretty close to home
no judge is ever going to tell you that
you didn't score very well you know the
important thing is you're just being
creative in a different way
Oh